so I have new polling from the Herschel
Walker Raphael Warnock race but what I
want to make sure everybody knows
is that this polling is from before the
abortion Scandal okay so it's we don't
yet know the effect of the abortion
Scandal but there is some good news
based on new polling there's a Fox News
poll that now is part of the mix and I
know people say Fox News Fox News
polling is actually fine it's a totally
fine poster on average
Raphael Warnock is now ahead of Herschel
Walker by 1.3 points now again important
caveats all of this polling is from
before the abortion Scandal and I'm
calling it that I don't believe abortion
is a scandal but it's the abortion
Scandal meaning Herschel Walker for a
year campaigning on abortion is the
absolute worst thing in the world now
credibly accused of having paid for a
woman's abortion after urging her to get
that abortion so the polling is from
before that Scandal we don't know yet
how that Scandal will affect the polling
and number two this is too tiny a lead
to really Bank on right so up until a
few days ago Walker was up by like under
one point now Warnock is up by a little
over a point this is all way too small a
lead to assume anything one way or the
other everyone must vote I hope that
you're registered uh in Georgia and uh I
hope that you plan to vote because this
is you know we talk about what are the
most important Senate races on which uh
this election could could hinge control
of the Senate could hinge Pennsylvania
is at the top of the list but Georgia is
close as well 538 has one of these
um sort of uh I don't know we call it
forecasts for I think they they call it
they are calling the Georgia Senate
election a toss-up but it is swinging
more and more in warnock's favor
yesterday they had it at a 54 chance
that Warnock wins now 538 has it at a 50
five percent chance that Warnock wins
now that's that's basically a coin flip
right if you got to flip 100 coins
and one guy wins 55 and the other you
know it's heads 55 times and Tails 45.
that's very very close to a toss-up and
as you can see there has been a little
bit of a bump recently for Warnock but
really not much so we'll see what the
um effect of the abortion Scandal is but
don't think for a second that's staying
home in this one is a good idea because
control of the Senate could hinge on it
let's hope that Warnock grabs a couple
of points uh thanks to this abortion
related Herschel Walker scandal